OF THE FLOW IS STUNNING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
CASEY STEGALL.
JOHN.
>> John: FLORIDA CONGRESSMAN
BYRON DONALDS FOR THOUGHTS ON
THIS.
SCENE AT LINCOLN HOSPITAL IN THE
BRONX OVER THE WEEKEND, HUNDREDS
OF ILLEGAL MIGRANTS WERE LINED
UP OUTSIDE, FREE HEALTHCARE,
FREE FOOD, EVEN GETTING FREE
PHONES.
AND SOME PEOPLE TAKE A LOOK AT
THIS AND ARE OUTRAGED, LOOK,
THERE ARE PLENTY OF PEOPLE IN
NEW YORK CITY WHO CANNOT MAKE
ENDS MEET, WHY ARE WE TAKING
CARE OF ILLEGAL MIGRANTS.
THEY WERE DROPPED THERE IN NEW
YORK CITY WITH PROBABLY NOT MUCH
TO THEIR NAMES.
BUT THEN AT THE SAME TIME,
YOU'VE GOT THESE TOWNS ON THE
BORDER THAT ARE JUST CRUMBLING
UNDER THE CRUSH OF ALL OF THESE
ILLEGAL MIGRANTS.
SO, A LOT OF PEOPLE IN THE
COUNTRY LOOK AT THIS AND SAY YOU
HAVE TO TAKE CARE OF THEM, BUT
WHY CAN'T YOU TAKE CARE OF OTHER
PEOPLE, AND WHAT ARE YOU
THINKING ABOUT ALL OF THIS?
>> WHAT I THINK IS, IF YOU HAVE
DEMOCRAT POLITICIANS, NOT JUST
JOE BIDEN, BUT MARK KELLY OF
ARIZONA, NEVADA, MAYOR ADAMS OF
NEW YORK, MAYOR BOWSER OF
WASHINGTON, D.C., IF THEY
SUPPORT THIS KIND OF A POLICY AT
OUR BORDER THEN THEY SHOULD BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
CONSEQUENCES.
YOU HAVE BORDER TOWNS ALL
THROUGHOUT THE SOUTHERN BORDER
WHO NEVER ASKED FOR A WIDE OPEN
BORDER.
JOE BIDEN WANTED TO DO IT,
DEMOCRAT POLITICIANS HAVE
SUPPORTED IT, THEY NEED TO BE
THE ONES TO PAY FOR IT.
IT'S JUST THAT SIMPLE.
IF YOU HAVE BORDER TOWNS BEAR
THE BURDEN WHILE LIBERALS IN THE
NORTHEAST IGNORE THE PROBLEM
THEY CREATED, YOU ARE ONLY GOING
TO GET MORE OF A PROBLEM.
WHAT IS HAPPENING IS A POLITICAL
AND HUMANITARIAN CATASTROPHE.
BUT THIS IS BROUGHT TO US BY THE
DEMOCRAT PARTY, SO THESE MAJOR
BLUE CITIES, THEY SHOULD BE THE
ONES TO HAVE TO DEAL WITH SOME
OF THE BURDEN CAUSED BY THEIR
TERRIBLE BORDER POLICY.
>> John: SO THE GOVERNORS OF
TEXAS AND ARIZONA ARE COMING IN
FOR CRITICISM FROM DEMOCRATS FOR
PUTTING PEOPLE ON BUSSES AND
IT'S VOLUNTARY, AND THEN SENDING
THEM TO EITHER WASHINGTON, D.C.
OR NEW YORK CITY.
BUT THE SAME TIME THE TWO
GOVERNORS ARE COMING UNDER
CRITICISM, THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS SENDING THOUSANDS
OF PEOPLE ON AIRPLANES, BUSSES
AND OTHER TRANSPORTATION ACROSS
COUNTRY TO SETTLE THEM IN CITIES
THAT ARE OVERBURDENED WHEN IT
COMES TO SOCIAL SERVICES.
>> YOU ARE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS BEEN
DOING THAT SINCE LAST FEBRUARY.
IF YOU HAVE FLOWN AMERICAN
AIRLINES OR SOUTHWEST AIRLINES,
THERE ARE IMMIGRANTS ON THE
PLANES.
JOE BIDEN'S BORDER POLICY IS
SUBSIDIZING THE DRUG CARTELS.
THE CARTELS WILL MAKE
$15 BILLION A YEAR AND I DON'T
HEAR DEMOCRATS COMPLAINING ABOUT
MIGRANTS TRAFFICKED INTO THE
UNITED STATES BY THE DRUG
CARTELS.
I DON'T HEAR THEM COMPLAINING
ABOUT THE DRUG CARTELS MAKING
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS MORE PER
YEAR AND DON'T HEAR THEM
COMPLAINING ABOUT THE YOUNG
GIRLS WHO ARE BEING RAPED AND
YES, I SAID RAPED IN THE JOURNEY
OF BEING TRAFFICKED BY THE DRUG
CARTELS.
WHEN IT COMES TO THAT, THEY GOT
NOTHING TO SAY BECAUSE THEY WANT
THE OPEN BORDER POLICY.
BUT WHEN ABBOTT AND DUCEY SEND
THEM TO NEW YORK AND D.C., NOW
THEY ARE COMPLAINING.
HYPOCRISY AT ITS WORST.
>> John: AND IN WASHINGTON,
D.C., EDITORIAL SAYING D.C.
CANNOT WISH AWAY MIGRANT BUSSES,
THE CITY MUST PREPARE FOR MORE.
BUT CONGRESSMAN, ANOTHER
PROBLEM.
SOME 250,000 UNACCOMPANIED
MINORS RESETTLED IN THE COUNTRY.
WHEN THEY BECOME ADULTS WILL PUT
US IN ANOTHER CRISIS POSITION
WHERE YOU HAVE TO DECIDE WHAT TO
DO WITH THEM.
DO YOU INITIATE DEPORTATION
PROCEEDINGS AGAINST THEM OR DOES
THIS BECOME DACA 2.0.
>> LOOK, IN MY VIEW, YOU HAVE TO
BEGIN DEPORTATION PROCEEDINGS.
JOE BIDEN HAS ALLOWED FOR ALL OF
THIS, AND NOT JUST HIM.
YOU HAVE DEMOCRATS IN THE SENATE
WHO HAVE NOT LIFTED A FINGER TO
STOP THIS PROBLEM, THEY
ENCOURAGE IT.
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO?
INUNDATE THE UNITED STATES WITH
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE THROUGH THIS
RECKLESS POLICY AND OH, OOPS,
NOW WE HAVE TO MAKE THEM
CITIZENS OR PATHWAY TO
CITIZENSHIP, TERRIBLE POLICY.
NOBODY SUPPORTS IT.
THE DEMOCRATS CANNOT PASS IT IN
CONGRESS SO THEY ARE GOING TO DO
IT WITH THE BLUNT FORCE OF NO
ENFORCEMENT AT THE SOUTHERN
BORDER SO EVERYBODY HAS TO DEAL
WITH THAT QUESTION.
TERRIBLE POLITICS, BUT THIS IS
WHAT HAPPENED WHEN YOU HAVE A
PARTY COMMITTED TO IDEOLOGY AS
OPPOSED TO THE FACTS ON THE
GROUND AND WHAT IT MEANS IN SO
MANY CITIES ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
>> John: